here is a woman who started crying she  started crying because she misses trump  so much this country trump loves this  country i love my country  we need to straighten this country up i  have children and we need  we need you trump our country is going  yeah i agree with you i'm gonna give you  a hug man this is why this is why we do  this for people like you because we know  how important it is for we know we love  this country and we know exactly  this is more sad than anything else i  mean you know crying because trump was  president makes more sense like crying  because it's it was such a terrible  a terrible episode in this country says  like that would make sense you know it  was horrible it was absolutely  humiliating globally crying because you  want the guy back so bad that is just  very very strange